classify the triangle below using its
sides and angles so there's three
classifications when it comes to sides
you might not have any of the sides be
the same length in which case you would
be dealing with a scalene triangle
so this is let me just draw an example
of a scalene triangle maybe make it a
little bit clearer that it is scalene
so i'm going to make a clearly a scalene
triangle
so none of the sides are equal if two of
the sides are equal you are dealing with
an isosceles
isosceles triangle so it might look
something like that where this side is
equal to that side right over there and
if all three sides have the same length
you are dealing with an equilateral
equilateral triangle so an equilateral
triangle might look like this all three
sides have the exact same length so over
here they give us the three sides one is
of length four
one is of length three point one one is
of length four point eight none of them
are the same length so this is a scalene
this is a scalene triangle and that's
just thinking about the sides now when
it comes to angles we care about how
wide open the angles open up so there's
a couple of scenarios if all of the
angles are less than 90 degrees we call
it an acute triangle
an acute triangle if one of the angles
is 90 degrees we call it a right
triangle so if none of them if none of
them if all of them are less than 90
it's an acute triangle if one of them is
90 degrees it is a right triangle and if
one of them is larger than 90 degrees it
is an obtuse triangle
it is an obtuse triangle and just as an
example
an acute triangle would be something
like this all of these are less than 90
degrees a right triangle would look like
that where you have 190 degree angle and
you can't have two or three or 90 degree
angles you can only have one 90 degree
angle and then an obtuse triangle would
look like this
would look like this where you have one
angle that is obtuse like this one right
over here where that angle is greater
than 90 degrees so if we look at our
example right over here this is less
than 90 degrees this is less than 90
degrees and that is less than 90 degrees
so it is an acute
it is an acute triangle when you look at
it from a point of angles so you could
call this triangle an acute scalene
triangle